hey brother so this is the guy I was
telling you about Brian Finch he's good
with complicated stuff and I think he
might be able to help you out what's
going on my wife died last night Kristen
died last night what happened I spend
like they're gonna happen
I watched the link go out of her eyes so
there's someone else in your apartment
did you try to stop him it's just just
me and her
my hand was wrapped around Kristen's
throat Neman was over I called my mom
one
I'm sorry mr. Shah sounds like you're
saying you killed her why I don't know I
was attached to the thing to kill
Kristin I didn't do it it was this thing
my arm it went crazy or something it
strangled Kristin's death but I wasn't
controlling it was acting on its own I
tried to pry the fingers off I tried to
to power the thing down nothing worked
so you're saying you're innocent but
you're hard how hard a stealthy yes I
know how it sounds believe me but it's
what happened I did not kill Kristin I
would never kill her it was my arm
you